welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Richard Ruby ascus professor of
anthropology and director of the Yale
reproductive ecology laboratory and the
why IBS program in reproductive ecology
professor Bree BS kisses most notable
research involves the evolutionary
biology and endocrinology of human and
comparative life histories reproduction
aging and metabolism he is the author of
men evolutionary and life history today
we talk with Professor bribie ascus
about the male species from a life
history and evolutionary perspective and
what it may hold for our future welcome
professor Velasquez Thank You Marilyn
thank you for having me you have spent a
good many years studying the human male
species and have arrived at a new way of
understanding them while we're pretty
much all familiar with evolutionary
theory it's the addition of the life
history theory that you bring that
provides a new approach tell us about it
well life history theory actually has a
pretty long history it's actually I
would say a part of evolutionary theory
and in basic terms it's sort of looking
at a species whether or not you're
looking you're thinking of humans or
fruit flies or whatever in terms of
specific events during the course of
their life such as when they're born how
long does it take for them to mature
when did it become reproductively mature
how long did they reproduce and
ultimately when do they die okay and we
know that a lot of the the timing of
those events are the results of
constraints constraints on your time
constraints on energy in terms of how
much food you can get from the
environment and what we're finding right
now is that life history theory can
inform us
in pretty powerful ways in terms of how
we we actually understand human biology
okay and what are some of the specific
things you look at to do that well one
of the ways we do this me and many of my
colleagues is to look at hormones and
what I tell my students is what what is
in anthropology is doing mucking around
with hormones but it has to do with the
fact that allah by allah g is the result
of the interaction between the
environment and your genes and hormones
are wonderful way of sort of looking to
that interaction they sort of there are
the liaison if you will of the
information that comes from the
environment your hormones sort of sense
is there a lot of food around is there
made around it's certainly your hormones
sort of adjust accordingly and then they
go in and sort of tinker with your genes
in hopefully an appropriate way for
whatever the environment is uh is
placing in front of you okay and after
all of this research that you've done
what can you tell us why are men the way
they are what are some of your
conclusions well men in contrast to
women have different constraints they
have different strains in their life and
those constraints are pretty common
across mammals they're not really
completely unique to humans there are
some unique things about humans but a
lot of the constraints are we see in
humans are common in other animals such
as the fact that metabolically one of
the biggest differences is that men or
male mammals period don't invest a lot
metabolically in reproduction men don't
gestate they don't lactate they don't
menstruate and so men don't have those
metabolic costs that women have to deal
with during the course of their life and
it really affects everything from their
behavior to their reproductive
strategies to their immune system so
those are some of some of the key
differences okay and what are some of
the things that may help us understand
how we will be in the future well what's
interesting is
if you understand the constraints that
women are under compared to men a lot of
it has to do with child rearing a lot of
it has to do with how much time you have
to spend raising your children and since
men can do a lot of things they can take
care of children I can do a lot of
things but they can't lactate at least
not under normal circumstances so what's
interesting is I think in the future
some of those constraints may be lifted
on women as they become more
economically and politically empowered
sometimes as we know having a male
partner is it even necessary to have a
child so I think what's interesting is
how the these these constraints that
were common throughout our evolution in
some instances aren't as relevant as
they were in the past I think they'll
still be things that will have to deal
with that it's interesting how I think
women in particular don't aren't under
the same constraints in many ways as
they were in the past do you think we'll
we'll find any new kinds of constraints
or difficulties moving forward with
these changes I think so I think
regardless of whether or not you have a
biological constraint there's always
economic constraints there's always
constraints on your time if you become
more economically empowered it comes at
a cost you have to spend more time at
work you invest more time with their
colleagues building relationships and
that's time spent away from your family
or your friends or whoever so there's
always going to be trade-offs which is
one of the to me one of the appeals of
life history theory because the core of
trade-offs applies even when you're
outside of the force if you're outside
of the which you think of natural
environment and in urban environment you
still have a lot of those constraints
and how does your theory apply to some
contemporary health concerns like
prostate cancer for instance or male
contraception hmm well in terms of we'll
start with with prostate cancer there
are costs and benefits to being in an
energy rich environment like we do so I
can leave the studio and walk down the
street and get a slice of pizza or have
it delivered and have lots of calories
with virtually no
effort and because I'm able to get those
calories I can afford to have higher
hormone levels like testosterone level
testosterone comes with a metabolic cost
and because it's higher I can build more
muscle if I wanted to if I want to
really hit the gym hard or something but
at the same time later on in life those
higher testosterone levels might
contribute to a higher risk of prostate
cancer since testosterone can increase
your risk of prostate cancer not at an
individual level but at a population
level in terms of things like a male
contraceptive I think it's interesting
to understand the motivation for men in
terms of why they would want to take a
male contraceptive women take
contraceptives because they want to
regulate the cost of benefits of having
children throughout their life it's a
good time at that time socially or
economically what have you mm-hmm for
men it's a little bit different since
they don't bear a lot of those costs
they don't again they don't gestate they
don't lactate so the motivation for
taking a male contraceptive maybe a
little bit different I think there may
be more of a market if you will if for
men who actually have a lot of research
wealthy men if you will and who may have
more of an incentive to I think to sort
of keep a closer eye if you will on
their reproduction okay and can you
speculate on how the human male species
will evolve down the road what do you
think we'll see Oh down the road if you
really consider some of my colleagues
some of the wonderful research you're
doing I think you're probably going to
see a lot more investment by males in
their offspring because I think part of
female empowerment is the fact that men
are going to have to negotiate with
women more about reproduction and a lot
of that negotiation is going to involve
investing more and children sticking
around help raising them investing in
them economically with their time their
resources so I think in the future if we
hopefully see more empowerment of women
I think you'll see men investing more in
childcare
more than you know even though humans
actually do invest a lot more in child
care than most other primates but I
think it's probably on the uptick okay
very good thank you so much for being
here today and sharing some of your
research thank you for more information
about professor Bree BS kiss and his
research please visit our website at
yale edu backslash Macmillan report be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale